nell'episodio precedente buongiorno
sorella qualcosa per me cazzo qualcuno
sta arrivando
oddio oddio cosa tu non puoi passare è
il cane di penombra o cazzo mi va bene
così
bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono vari j
oggi andiamo avanti con matt father
eravamo rimasti oh cazzo
ok siamo partiti subito maledizione
erano rimasti nell'ultimo episodio che è
praticamente c'era sto zombie che
strisciando tenta di stuprare tutte le
maniere possibili e in pratica non
riusciva a superarlo la ragazza hanno
[ __ ] il cane di penombra cia [ __ ]
la chiave e dobbiamo riprenderlo è
andato di qua solo che io di qua non ci
posso andare perché c'è quel maledetto
stronzo che passa e non so allora
ragazzino arrampicarmi serie a qualcosa
mi dice che arrampicarsi non era la
maniera giusta
[Musica]
che culo che culo assurdo braga ce
l'abbiamo fatta ma posso essere così
[ __ ] ma si può essere così
deficienti
ma cazzo ma dai rack per passare alle
scale se non c'ha le gambe hanno
veramente cela le gambe sono io che sono
migliora di merda mamma mia che
deficiente ma cos'è non penso che io
possa raggio a voi la vuoi raggiungere
il lampadario che cosa sei
prince of persia maledizione allora cosa
devo fare devo lanciarmi a voi che
raga ho un'idea assurda ho un'idea
madonna mia se mi viene
mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia
no no non ci voglio credere
ma la lazio allo ragazzi ho capito cosa
devo fare
ma sono talmente idiota che riesco a
sbagliare dieci volte di fila
stai calma ho capito allora deve
interessare ma qui volevo metterla lì ok
però giustamente ci serve contro peso
perché se mi butto come un deficiente in
punta è naturale che cade la tavola
allora prendo sacco lo sposto asi si può
funzionare vai che può funzionare ho
deciso io e chiaro che funziona questa
faceva due sacchi perfetto la sua punta
è risolto tutto abbiamo appurato che hai
appesa come due sacchi di patate
perfetto andiamo avanti
vai con la motosega mamma mia che mira
che mia brutto stronzo becca chi questo
sulla testa e la prossima volta ti ci
cado in piedi bastardo ok
scusatemi questo era uno sfogo personale
perché ci stava a sto punto direi di
aprire questa porta qui che non si apre
perfetto regalo disintegrato non c'è più
va bene così sinceramente non me ne
fotte un cazzo va bene fuori c'è un
altro coatti cornice c'è un pokémon
non mi ricordo dove si chiama quello è
un [ __ ] pokémon quello nella delle
teche non mi ricordo come si chiama
marcia un nome
vabbè questa porta è chiusa penoni
portando avanti c'è un barile aperto
siamo sempre stati chiusi finora perché
ce n'è uno aperto
[Musica]
perché c'è qualcuno dentro chi è questo
non si sa chi è ma noi per rispetto nei
suoi confronti lo calpestiamo vabbè
apriamo e cos'è questo bastò troppo no i
puzzle no vi prego i puzzle no ci metto
12 ore e mezzo ragazzi dai dai dai dai
dai dai dai
ne manca una ne manca una se ce l'ho
fatta ho sentito un suono da qualche
parte perfetto si è sbloccato qualcosa
probabilmente la porta si è aperta
perché tu ce l'abbiamo fatta
ok ci ho messo un'ora e mezzo raga
perché non riusciva dalla difesa ma
giustamente ce l'ho fatta allora tu mi
vuoi vi dovete spiegare chi è questo una
misteriosa pianta donne qui dentro nelle
piante dormono giustamente c'erano anche
casa alle librerie
a proposito delle piante non mi cos'è un
lavorato perché una scappata una esca
una pianta ragazza è una pianta
selvatica in giro ed è qui sotto l'ho
vista
vuoi estirpare la pianta sinceramente no
però facciamo mi sembra tipo quella di
harry potter che l'anzhi è fatta è
quella di harry potter rimetti là dentro
che sarà ma no al cazzo sono svenuto ma
ho preso a la mandragola era la
mandragola sia vera adesso ma sono
ricordata
vabbè era una pianta è uguale harry
potter sperimentiamo preso il vaso ho
preso il vaso
devo portarla in un punto dove se la
tirò fuori non fa casino dove posso
tirarla fuori in modo che non faccia
casini non lo so in acqua forze non lo
so
tra l'altro qua c'è una strada che non
ho ancora visto non ci sono andato prima
ok c'è una caramella rara ho trovato un
marte martello allora tu brutto stronzo
c'hai la mia [ __ ] chiave ok ragazzi
può funzionare non ne sono sicuro ma può
funzionare allora aspettate un attimo
anche la mandragola però non c'è
paraorecchi svengo anch'io ma cadono a
terra tourè lo sapevo lo sapevo che il
cazzo devo fare raga forse ho capito
alla società da un attimo si non mi dite
che ragazze tutto martella serviva
qualcosa o scassato il tamburo spero che
ci trovi qualcosa per l'orecchio ok sono
i cosi per le orecchie se ce l'abbiamo
fatta la gara ce l'abbiamo fatta
è un miracolo che io abbia trovato
subito la soluzione ci avrei messo
secoli allo ragazzi già facciamo da
piano andiamo qui poi così per gli ho
già messi mi sa che lo fa in automatico
arapaj cos'è stordirci quello stronzo ma
li hai messi così per l'orecchino perché
sono se ce l'abbiamo fatta
ok ragazzi allora adesso il cane anda
perfetto mandato adesso mi segue un
pokémon è diventato no rimane che sta se
ne va per i cazzi sua è va bene così non
interessa fai quello che vuoi è stordito
non me ne frega nulla prendi la chiave
non è che se l'è mangiata
ok non devo squartarlo evidentemente
almeno fino non debba usare questo ok
perfetto lo sapeva che tanto dovevo fare
scusami scusami un cazzo da [ __ ] la
chiave
va bene quel cane l'ho sempre unita
penombra che lo detesto quindi puoi fare
quello che vuoi per quanto mi riguarda
ho trovato la chiave dell'inceneritore
oh mio dio sa cos'è stringere il cuore
ci punto la mamma ok ragazzi allora
nello scorso episodio trovato la bambola
che devo bruciare sono cadute le ventole
che cazzo il successo ora che accaduto
qualcosa è accaduto qualcosa non so dopo
[Applauso]
a sto punto direi di tornare indietro
non mi interessa aprile con la [ __ ]
porta ho trovato la chiave
dell'inceneritore
il problema è che non so dov'è
l'inceneritore se sapessi dove ha forse
questo qui non è questo qui a meno che
non sia st porta quando non penso ok
perfetto non trovata ci siamo ragazzi
inceneritore è bene siamo a questo cazzo
bottacin anello frodo vabbè ci sono le
fiamme ardenti perfetto brutta ci sta
bambola di merda e libera la terra di
merda or dalle fiamme chi sapeva che
questo si trova qui sotto a quasi sta
ricordando cosa le aveva detto se
distruggerai quella bambola passerà ai
avendo fatto che la voce più mal
recitata di sempre ma non importa
brucia la e bruciata anche la sua anima
all'interno e dopodichè la barriera
invisibile sparirà
ok ragazzi buttiamoci la bambola è
perfetto si buttiamoci st maledetta
bambola vai così botta la via anche
gollum vuoi distruggermi si voglia
distruggerti non mi piace più sono
troppo grande per giocare con le bambole
non aprirò quella porta se lo farai
brutto stronzo nuvole capri milan e
anche prima
allora lo vedremo fermate per favore
fermati aia conosce anche mio nome
capasso premio nome mamma per favore hai
ascoltato madre lo è un trucco fermati
tu non sei mia madre brava ya vai così
voglio vederti mia splendida figlia
fermate verso la non devo animarla farfa
anche lei ok brutta lanese e tv
è un riferimento assurdo al signore
degli anelli raga sta diventando un
plagio sto gioco qualcosa sul mi piace
vi giuro mi piace un casino sta cosa che
ci sono dei riferimenti la d'oro è
fantastica e l'ho buttata da ragazzi se
tutto va bene dovremmo aver aperto la
porta di sotto c'è quella che prima era
chiusa la ragazza e andiamo sono curioso
di vedere chi è questo cos'è il corpo di
una bambola con i vestiti cambiati
ok e che cazzo me ne frega a me così
cosa mi rappresenta
cosa dovrei farci questa roba niente non
posso prendere anche cazzola nome sa
fare cos'è aprono un negozio di intimo
non ho capito nemo avanti c'è quella col
colte e morta è morta che casa perché è
morta la camicia o dio sono morti perché
morto addio sono tutte morte cazzola
gara perché non c'è più la testa che è
successo oddio oddio raga che è successo
chi è passato di qua fatemi capire cosa
è successo raga qualcuno e qualcuno è
passato e ha squarciato le teste non so
chi cazzo è obbligato era già morto
nello stesso episodio quindi va bene
però resto non lo so è stata la sua
l'esorcista lo so e ragazzini o avanti
perché non so chi è stato il di ancora
lì quello è lì dallo schema donna c'è
rimasto da un bel pezzo vero
mio dio si starà anche un po rompendo il
caso va bene scopriremo se si è aperta
la porta finalmente vai fa che si apra
che ce l'abbiamo fatta siamo passati
oltre ragazzi sarà qualcosa tipo un
filmato penso sia infatti questo odio un
portale che cazzo successo un po
fantastico cioè professor layton questo
ti porterà in un altro mondo
[Musica]
il professor layton ragazzi ci siamo mi
mancava e lì davanti se vuoi veramente
andare quindi lasciami che ti porgo a
questo usa voltarmi non farmi pensare
male cos'è un anello professore cos'è
questo mister è e dell'acqua magica un
prodotto della mia compagnia a questo
qui è un venditore porta a porta che
emenda acque magiche per favore porta la
conte ok i poteri quest'acqua ti aiuterà
senza dubbio posso salvare mio padre con
questo quindi certo l'acqua un potere
per scacciare il male quindi io posso
fermare la maledizione ma devo salvare
mamma quindi e pregherò per la tua
salvezza si devo andare alla ragazzi
devo entrare nel portale devo entrare
nel portale o mio dio tipo brivio
entriamo nel portare in un altro mondo
ok ragazzi siano perfetto mio dio è una
cosa contro no la motosega
così lei andata vedremo se questo lo
porterà alla fine che è successo
mister mi ha [ __ ] di brutto secondo
me questo sapeva delle cose che io non
so c'è un cristallo ragazzi cè un
cristallo rosso è meglio che mi muova
c'è un cristallo ai per salvare abbiamo
praticamente non ci sono più i corpi ma
ci sono i cristalli salviamo in fondo
vai così bene cosa dovrei fare
dimenticare
porca [ __ ] che figo che figata assurda
c'è un altro porta andiamo di portare in
portale è fantastico non accetto questo
fino a dio c'è il padre la madre
ragazzi siamo arrivati in un punto madre
che quindi sia arrivata ai ha quindi se
veramente tu mamma mamma perché non
dovrei non saresti dovuta venire alle
atrocità che questo uomo continua a
commettere
non voglio che facciano voglio che miete
più vittime stai mentendo
se qualcuno capiva mio padre di tua
mamma e maria maria boa con dio non
avevo notato maria adesso sa che è morta
non lamu vista è solo maria che a te non
piace vero mamma penso che vada letta
con un tono malvagio ma non era malvagio
non voglio darlo a nessuno voglio
portarlo via con me no non puoi senza
papà sarò da sola non voglio stare da
sola voglio soltanto vivere con papà e
ne sono felice quando sono con te e papà
quindi non lasciarmi sola
ma dio mia santo si è voluta
nessuno deve interferire o mio dio sia
indemoniata raga o mio dio mamma ora
tesoro lasciati andare
no sto portando via papa no ma dai che
cosa a janò c svegliato il papa papa
perché è il papa è ok cielo più vicino
adesso posso prenderlo aia perché non
vuoi ascoltarmi non portartelo via via
dalla mia strada
ok mamma nessuno deve averlo ma hanno
fermati e lui è soltanto mia
cos'è questo mister lacko magica mio
prodotto ci sarà un momento in cui ti
servirà di sicuro non ho dubbi che ti
aiuterà ok raga penso che dobbiamo usare
l'acqua magica posso salvare mio padre
con questa ma per quanto riguarda la
mamma non sono così sicura ma lo devo
fare
salva papa oppure esaudisce il desiderio
di mamma devo decidere io il finale ma
no ci sono le ragazze un bivio ci sono
due finali ma mio addio allora ragazzi
indipendentemente da cosa scelgo adesso
io farò entrambi finali quindi in un
altro episodio vedrete l'ennesimo finale
non c'è soltanto questo state tranquilli
comunque io vado alla cieca e direi che
seguo questo cosa secondo scelto salva
la mamma a ok è il desiderio della mamma
scusami papa
ok non ho salvato mi quale però mi
dispiace lei diaby di qualsiasi altra
persona non posso portarti via la mamma
mi dispiace io cosa ho fatto perché ho
scelto suo figlio
mio dio perché ho scelto sto finale
maledizione ma dai non possono mio dio è
andato via perfetto siamo tornati
dovevamo prima dove sono
sono tornato indietro sì sì tornati
indietro che è successo raga sono
tornato cieco
ok non è ok perfetto raga io pensavo
fosse finito ma non è finito ok allora
dov'è che ho salvato nell'altro mondo
ok il salvataggio più in basso è quello
dell'altro mondo quindi devo ma io avevo
letto nei commenti che per sbloccarti
tutti finali devi raccogliere tutte le
gemme 15 allora forse ci sono più di due
finali non ce ne sono soltanto due c'è
allora ci sono quei due più forse un
altro speciale che raccolgo che prendo
raccogliendo tutte le gemme forse vabbè
comunque quello lo vedrò lo vedro alla
fine allora ragazzi è successo di tutto
io direi che per questo episodio posso
concludere qui non è ancora finito
pensavo di essere arrivato al finale ma
non ci siamo ancora ci arriveremo
probabilmente nel prossimo episodio e
poi di sicuro farò anche gli altri
comunque sono davvero curiosa di come
andrà a finire ogni episodio è sempre
meglio
io sto gioco veramente lo amo alla
follia veramente ragazzi vi ringrazio
per avermi consigliato perché è
fantastico
[Musica]
c'è del sangue all'interno si può mica
aprire lo scopriremo nel prossimo
episodio laga 6 mi dove piaciuto
lasciato un commento vi piace anche alla
pagina di facebook che come in ogni viso
trovate nella descrizione se non siete
ancora i siti iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo
e noi ci vediamo in un prossimo video
bella ragazzi